to get the lowdown on paris how about a
trip down the seine past the palais
bobon
taking in the louvre
and the musee d'orsay
among the many other historic sites
the il de la cite
the island boasting notre dame cathedral
and the eiffel tower
my favorite were the architecture of all
the different bridges
the sheer size of paris is impressive
i find it a very emotional experience
there's so much history in these
buildings
the best part was the bells of notre
dame
the masterpiece of gothic architecture
in the heart of paris is the city's top
attraction
beating even the eiffel tower
the cathedral draws over 13 million
visitors a year
the most impressive thing is being here
in the middle of all the noise of paris
and feeling this inner peace
and inner silence
is the bird market
locals and tourists alike block here
every sunday
even the stall owners revel in the
riverside scene
in this line of work you have to stay
calm otherwise you disturb the birds
and paris just wouldn't be the same
without the buccaneers
some of the vendors lining the banks of
the seine have been selling their
antique books postcards and engravings
here for decades
books in general might be harder to sell
these days but this book on east loves
his job
because i'm all alone
and it's all up to me
and it doesn't feel like work
julia pollock likes the more colorful
but less touristy areas in the north of
the city
the german french artist finds no
shortage of ideas here
especially at the fish market
the fish
inspired the fish and all the colors
give me inspiration for my work
all the different patterns the fish have
and i like the atmosphere here
the fish motif
in reality and in the art of yulia
pollock
she's a frequent visitor to montmartre
the highest hill in the city is teaming
with artists and tourists
sakura church sits majestically
overlooking the city below
by law no more than two artists per
square meter are allowed on the place
duterte nearby
the history of
includes picasso and salvador dali
ever since then artists have been coming
here to work and live
heart fans also head to the orangery in
the twilory garden the museum is famous
for being the home of claude monet's
water lilies
the paintings depict the impressionist
painters own garden outside paris
we then take in the place de l'etoid
with the arc de triomphe and the
champs-elysees for hitting the ultra
swiss avenue montagna
it's brimming with luxury fashion labels
and tourists
for a classic taste of paris sample the
macarons
available in all manner of colors and
flavors
brassaris are a relaxing option for
winding down in the evening
the grand colbert is a typical example
later in the evening
oysters and lobster are especially
popular
we like the atmosphere
and the ambiance
and it's very nice there
and
you get good food
the nights are long in paris
just down the hill from montmartre you
can't miss the moulin rouge
the legendary cabaret theater offers a
flashy finale to any paris soldier